[Music]
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast I'm Bryan Keating
you're lately very fearful host usually
not quite this fearful but during
pandemic times we've created the
pandemic podcast series bringing
together the world's most brilliant
authors thinkers scholars scientists and
poets and all sorts of people that I'm
interested in just to be perfectly
candid and I hope that you out there and
the Internet are and by the amazing
reaction we're having it's it's going
quite well today is a real treat just
reached out to you Sascha Segan a couple
weeks ago would you please do me the
honor of coming on into the impossible
podcast and you said yes it's great to
to connect with you I want to thank you
for coming on the podcast now I talked a
little bit about about your wonderful
book but more spend time talking about
your philosophy and and your story which
i think is so unique and so meaningful
of course your book is called for
creatures such as we small creatures
such as we and if you needed any
inspiration from authority figures to
read this book you should go no further
than looking at the cover quote from
Bill Nye our favorite science guy he
said read her work you'll have a deeper
appreciation for your every step every
bite and every breath and the famous
self-declared militant atheist and we're
gonna talk about that because I think I
think of you as a militant centrist
you're very you're incredibly
parsimonious sorry parsimonious but
you're you're incredibly conciliatory
Concilium she strikes Concilium sizz
what I'm trying to say and I love that
but the militant atheists the so-called
the author of The God Delusion and other
things he wrote she's Carl Sagan's
daughter and it shows a charming book
ringing with the joy of existence
and the author had to to the great
Richards quote there is that you're also
an jury installer and and I think you
somehow managed to kind of channel both
of them and the book really resonated to
me as a father
of daughters and of sons and and also
just as a human being is that sort of a
pay on to your parents both Carl and an
and and also you as a mother and your
daughter and your husband and I thought
found it so refreshing
it truly is charming and you know I
think on The Simpsons once there was a
quote about a book that it's
unputdownable that Homer called the book
unfit honorable so I think if Homer gets
to the next blurb he would probably say
that and March to so I want to first
take this opportunity to wish you an
early happy Mother's Day we're recording
this a couple days before Mother's Day
2020 and I bet it's going to be a
Mother's Day unlike any other for all of
us or all the mothers and wives and
grandmothers out there in the world and
I wanted to talk about the way that the
book struck me after we get into a
description of the cover I unlike the
advice that's normally offered I judge
all books by their covers so walk us
through the cover we're gonna have
graphics for the YouTube Watchers for
creatures such small creatures such as
we rituals for finding meaning in our
unlikely world so you'll have to check
out the YouTube videos to see what the
cover actually looks like but Sasha can
you walk us through the cover design and
where the title and subtitle came from
well um first of all thank you so much
for having me Brian I'm delighted to be
with you in this strange new world where
it's all virtual the title of the book
comes from the line in in contact which
was the only work of fiction that my dad
ever published he and my mom together
wrote dozens of books and essays and the
original cosmos television show together
which he hosted but they had this idea
for for a work of fiction as first
content story and originally they wanted
it to be a movie but movies
it took a long time for that particular
movie to get made and in the meantime
they wrote it as a novel and the line
that the title of my book comes from my
mother actually wrote they collaborated
on everything and and this was something
that she had brought to the story and
it's the the rest of the line is for
small creatures such as we the vastness
is bearable only through love and for
those of us who are secular and those of
us who have to go through this kind of
existential crisis of we're tiny in this
gigantic universe and we don't know if
there's anything else out there or if
there's anything after we die or all
these deep philosophical questions where
we sort of have to hold space for
ambiguity via the other side of that
crisis to me is well what do we have we
have one another right here right now
and I think especially during this very
strange time we're in it feels so clear
you know the the longing to be together
with those that you miss the longing to
have those those feelings of
togetherness and the closeness you feel
if you're lucky enough to be quarantined
with some people you love the gratitude
that you have to be with them I think
just become so much crystal clear at
least to me in this time and so that's
where the title of the book came from
and the subtitle we went back and forth
the publishers and the marketing people
and my editor and we went back and forth
so many times because it sort of is a
strange combination of genre is this
book I mean there are elements that are
memoir and there are elements that are
sort of social history although I am NOT
a historian I just dream of being one
and they're elements that are sort of
almost give me prescriptive like I don't
want to say like how to the idea of this
is something you could do at home or
this is something you could adapt in
your own way and so we've really
went through a lot of different
incarnations to figure out a subtitle
that worked and indifferent so when in
the UK and Australia and New Zealand
where they have a different publisher
the title is the same the subtitle is
different which I thought was very
interesting but yeah it's really sort of
a exploration of what are how we keep
time and how we celebrate and how we
mourn and how we process change with or
without a particular theism yeah I just
can't resist just a call back to our one
of our more recent episodes with the
author Sarah skulls who wrote the
biography of Jill tarter who of course
is a loose inspiration as I understand
it for your father and mother and the
book contacted actually Sarah's current
book is called they are already here
about UFO sightings and her previous
book was about SETI so I asked her if
her next book is about yetis
Loch Ness monster what have you but she
she's tight-lipped on that but Annie but
she did right making contact where the
callback is to of course the name of
that book which is the origin of the at
least amend masthead title of this book
so it's nice to make that connection and
folks should check out those interviews
with with Jill Tartars biographer Sarah
skulls on the into the impossible back
catalogue and so the book you know the
the essence of ritual really does kind
of speak to me as many of my listeners
know I'm a practicing Jew I'm not an
Orthodox Jew I like to do that say that
for the benefit of of Orthodox Jews so
that they don't get into too much
trouble but I do want to first start
asking a little bit about some of the
connections the influence of Judaism on
your life obviously your secular but
you're not as I say you know militantly
so and and one of the things or
militantly atheists for sure and
certainly you've developed so many
rituals in your life that are new novel
ones from the welcoming of your daughter
continuing a one generation old
tradition into the second generation and
uh you know and and you really tie
together these beautiful connections
between the biological the astrological
the you know the physical nature of of
cycles and I think rituals don't exist
without cycles or without some notion of
times passage and I'll the only thing
I'll say about the books structure is
that it's ordered by season and kind of
seasons of life but I ask you a question
that came to me during the reading of
the book I read a lot of books on
leadership and you know being a good
leader and and well it's like you know
willpower is is useless like discipline
Trump's willpower every day and I think
well like what is better in the
hierarchy according to you Sasha do you
feel like willpower ritual habit you
know because you couldn't have you
talked about all sorts of different
habits and rituals from your husband so
lovingly providing you with morning
coffee at least before the baby or maybe
before the pandemic my wife so talk a
stir like the hierarchy in your mind
would you you know what do you think a
person should sort of rely on their
ritual a habit or their own willpower
and discipline I think that I mean it
just depends on what you need and what
you're looking for as a person what I
you know what I've really found in
ritual and so and in terms of my own
belief or lack thereof I consider myself
secular which is my position as I
reserve belief without evidence so I
don't think it's for me to say there is
definitely not this or there is
definitely that but the things that are
supported by evidence for me are so
breathtakingly astonishing and beautiful
that that has provided you know nature
as revealed by science has provided
enough for me enough wonder enough
enough sense of belonging in part of
something greater than myself that I
don't feel a call to that which relies
on face to
believed that said my ancestor I mean
when I take a DNA test you know kit and
the results come back it's like you are
like 99.999999%
no one's perfect session yeah what
traveling when I took the class my dad
said to me congratulations your genetic
garbage relying on science as your
worldview is that it's missing like
cuisine and expressions and holidays and
I am very big I love a celebration I
love a party I love to get dressed up I
love to mark time and I find it very
soothing and I think that that's
something that ritual provides and
allows us to process change because you
know that change as my mother always
says there is no refuge from change in
the cosmos it is constant it's the only
constant and it's very hard for us we
little creatures on this pale blue dot
to get our heads around it you know even
just like when you you know see someone
you haven't seen in a long time and
they're older you know births deaths
coming of age the changing of the
seasons these are the markers in our
lives because these are the signposts
that say everything is not forever and
some of the changes are cyclical and
some of them are permanent and I think
the reason that rituals elaborate ritual
is very private rituals all manner of
ritual have developed independently from
one another and so many disparate
cultures at such similar moments in our
lives is because we have some deep need
to to really take a step back and say
wow things are different today's and
they were yesterday or than they were
last year or whatever it is and so
something that I really connect to in
Judaism and so we have for example a
secular Passover Seder every year and we
Joe Monica but we do it from a
standpoint of this is what our ancestors
did you know beyond two or three
generations I don't know anybody's names
I don't know a village they came from
but I know that they were Jews and so
like when I light like a yard side
candle on the anniversary of the death
of someone that I loved I know that
somebody I came from somebody whose
qualities I have somewhere somehow
genetically did this at some point in
the last six thousand years and I find
that really soothing and meaningful
without requiring a theistic connection
yeah yeah I wonder when I was listening
to like I listened to it I read it and I
recommend all you know every single
listener buy and and get all three
different versions of this yeah I get I
get you know a nickel every purchase
does but I thought about it and you know
reminded me of and there's so much in
what you just said from you know belief
in science and evidence and and of
course in ritual just the last thing
I'll say about you know kind of habits
versus willpower you know so when my you
know wife and I are walking through some
you know the county fair and you know so
one of the kids wants you know something
deep-fried butter stick or something
yeah the easiest thing for us to do so
it's not kosher or sorry you know it's
like that trumps everything and then you
know lower down is like their own
willpower and then lower down is like
perhaps you know you know it's not the
way that we do things or something you
know along the scale of things it seems
like ritual has always had sort of a
religious connotation has a certainly
religious connotation we're going to
talk soon about a ritual and academia
that I'm going to run off to in an hour
but but but the but the you know when
people think about rituals especially
the marking time there is this
connotation of you know as Aristotle
said you are what you repeatedly do and
that time that's in in you know
imprinted so deeply in the throughout
your book and throughout what gives you
meaning I wonder you know like
you know just to be candid do you think
your daughter or your granddaughter or
your grandson you know are they going to
preserve these these these things as you
did or you know like for example Jews
have been observing Passover for
thousands of years or women you know
have been lighting yard side candles the
same the same kind of length of time or
in Christianity you detailed the history
of Christmas in your book so you know
art does it trouble you that you know in
a generation this ritual that was
important to you won't be important to
to your daughter because you know she
might not have the exact life trajectory
and of course we want our kids to be
their own unique individual people yeah
I mean it's just not yet my first and
you know what I mean like what she
chooses and what she believes and what
she does I can only present her with my
particulars and my husband can do the
same and our other friends and family
can do the same but I think the thing
that's so for me reassuring in a strange
way is that no matter how devout you are
no matter how seriously you take
tradition in they change over the eons
and you know they have to mutate in
order to survive
and no matter how deeply held your
belief is or your ritual is or whatever
you're doing over the course of human
history it's but a blink of an eye the
most traditional the most old-school the
most Orthodox you know in the small or a
larger you know it's it's it's new and
whatever it happens in the next couple
of generations for the next you know
hopefully if we don't we manage not to
destroy ourselves and hundreds of
generations for anything to to survive
it has to change and I can only give her
what I have which is very different then
you know what my great grandparents who
were Orthodox did and I can only say
this is a connection to the people who
came before you myself included
and people who
we don't know his name's we don't know
but she has but I think the weight of
ritual of the obligation of the feeling
that you have to do something because
you're you're carrying on a tradition if
it doesn't ring true for you or it
doesn't serve the purpose of helping you
process change or celebrate or find joy
or go through the process of grieving or
whatever it is that that it serves for
the individual I don't think that it's I
don't think that the weight of
obligation should force one's hand to do
something if it's not what's right for
them and you know I I probably am more
enthusiastic about rituals than my
parents were I mean we had Seder and we
had Chanukah something that put like
they didn't um
you know there wasn't like they were it
was nice and they liked it culturally
yeah exactly but like for me this is
like I like to throw a party like I get
into it and I think that in you know the
pendulum swings you know it could go
either way she may totally you know
leave off any any semblance of these
traditions my husband's not Jewish so
she also has the traditions from you
know Western European Christian ancestry
to choose from or something new or
something totally different and I think
that that has to be up to her because I
think both beliefs and lack of belief
they can't be forced you know it cannot
come from a place of like you said
militants it has to be what what what
rings true for the individual and it
really brings me I have to say to the
conversation between my grandfather and
my great-grandfather who was Orthodox
and I write about this in the book and
my grandfather you know his parents he
was born in New York but his parents
came from Eastern Europe and they
believed very very deeply and he went
off to college and you know got all
cosmopolitan and secular
and he came home and you know that like
as the story retold to me obviously many
decades later you know that like hey not
in the pit of his stomach waiting you
know to talk to his dad and he comes
home and he finds his dad jompa me and
he waits for him to finish and you know
very sheepish I bet you bet something
that um I'm not gonna go to shul anymore
I'm not gonna keep kosher anymore I'm
you know I don't believe and his father
looked up at him and said the only sin
would be to pretend and I just thought
you know by the time it was told to me
it was like a family mantra of legend
and I really I really think that that
that that to me is is the deepest thing
is that you you know in terms of this
stuff and just especially in terms of
ritual you know if if it doesn't ring
true for you you know and it doesn't
have any value I don't think that you
know even as as however fabulous my
faders may be when my daughter is an
adult if she doesn't want to throw them
you know that's on that's up to her what
I don't want is her to do it something
that's very labor intensive out of
obligation you know right yeah I guess
one thing that as you're saying that I
hadn't really thought made the
connection but you know there's a
statement I think Dawkins made this you
know that it's basically a crime you
know when when a kid is born to say oh
you are Christian like you nobody's
Christian from birth like your husband
could take a genetic test but it's not
gonna say what religion you know he
comes from with the accuracy and
specificity that we can take it as
Ashkenazi Jews predominantly and he
basically I mean I don't wanna put words
in his mouth and you know I'm better
than I do but it almost is like oh it's
like child abuse you know - like expose
a child to the religion of their his or
her birth and I do feel like it's it's
kind of disingenuous and I said this you
know in several different interviews
that I've given in connection to you
know my thoughts of Judaism and
observance in general as a practicing
scientist and as I as a person of
faith who is really more sort of
practicing agnostic in that I don't know
for certain that God exists but I see
you know like if God does exist is he
going or she you know I'm gonna say he
traditionally is he gonna say oh you
kept kosher like how dare you you know
basically and that there is sort of a
hierarchy in terms of religions not that
you know one is better than the other
but there's something about monotheism
verse non monotheism most your book is
concerned with monotheistic religions
and I just wonder you know when you when
you think about these rituals that are
observed is there not you know a class
distinction between a monotheistic faith
and kind of polytheistic or pantheistic
or even pagan and not not to mean like
you know heathens but but pagan istic in
terms of nature worship we see a lot of
movement nowadays towards you know I'll
say worship of the earth but really that
mother nature is sorry you know this got
Gaia and and and so forth whether or not
people actually I mean they do have
rituals right their you know their
rituals where we celebrate the earth and
and and there's good aspects of that as
well but what is your taking just the
main distinction that I think Judaism
came and did away with which is
monotheism versus polytheism let's say I
mean I don't really make a distinction
between belief between specific beliefs
to me if you're if there's two in my
mind there's two camps there's beliefs
that comes from evidence and that can
stand up scrutiny that doesn't rely on
faith and there's beliefs that relies on
face and your own experience and I don't
think you know whether you have one God
or a lot of gods or it's sort of
abstract you know I think that there are
certain great areas in terms of you know
what is a philosophy versus a religion
and not like Shintoism in Japan has sort
of elements of
philosophical connection to the earth
and to nature and it has religious
elements too but it sort of doesn't it's
at least from a Western perspective it
seems to bridge to a different area you
know to the two different areas of a
religion and the philosophy I think you
see that um from time to time but I
think that you know and if you go back
far enough you know this idea of science
versus religion that this that didn't
exist until there were questions that
could be answered by science that the
answer became in direct conflict with
the religious doctrine and I mean you
know
heliocentrism which comes to mind and I
think that for most of human history the
more deeply we understood nature really
understood it really understood the
patterns the phases of them and the
changing of the seasons the equinoxes
and solstices the closer we were to our
God or God's whether they were literal
or metaphorical singular or plural and I
think that this idea that those those
concepts are in conflict is relatively
new but no I don't I mean I'm really and
a lot of the book is concerned with with
monotheism as immature but a lot of it
actually is about you know ancient Greek
culture and which is Horus policy astok
and um you know other you know as I
mentioned like Shinto Azzam really
fascinates me because it has this
connection to nature that's so
respectful and celebratory and I think
that that is something that sometimes we
lose especially with monotheism not
always sometimes so now I want to turn
maybe a little bit to to the portion of
the book that speaks to me as a former
teacher along with Pulitzer
prize-winning poet ray armentrout we
taught a class called called poetry for
physicists so not the not the normal
class that you're used to here
and here's how we began the course and I
want I want to know your preference
between these two prose poems first and
I walk Walt Whitman and it's called
because because I think your book is it
as a rhyme - it has a poetic meter and
it's quite lovely and I think you'll
appreciate this so what women I wrote
this called when I heard the learn'd
astronomer when I heard the learn'd
astronomer when the proofs the figures
were ranged in columns before me when I
was shown the charts and diagrams to add
divide and measure them when I hurt when
I when I sitting heard the astronomer
when he lectured with much applause in
the lecture-room how soon unaccountable
I became tired and sick till rising and
gliding out I wandered off by myself in
the mystical moist night-air and from
time-to-time
looked up in perfect silence stars
that's that's poem number one phone
number two is not really thought of as a
poem but I think it is by a richard
fineman it actually doesn't have a title
to it but he says poets say science
takes away from the beauty of the stars
mere globs of gas atoms I too can see
the stars in the desert night and feel
them but do I see less or more the
vastness of the heavens stretches my
imagination stuck on this carousel my
little eye catches 1 million year old
light a vast pattern of which I am apart
what is the pattern or the meaning or
the why it does not do harm to the
mystery to know a little bit about it
for far more marvelous is the truth than
any of the artists of the past imagined
it why do the poets of the present not
speak of it what men are poets who can
speak of Jupiter if he were a man but if
he is an immense spinning sphere of
methane and ammonia must be silent so I
think I know which one you might prefer
but I'd like to hear from you I don't
know have you ever heard the Fineman yes
yes one first I figured you might be yes
can you talk about it is and sometimes
you know it's not always the it's the
delivery so often when we communicate
the grandeur of the universe and our
deep understanding of the beauty of
nature it we don't have the passion that
you see sometimes I mean the first
version of this that comes mine is like
a great preacher like that enthusiasm
that thrill that joy gets lost sometimes
I think that this is the connection
between those two between that
spine-chilling thrill and the true
nature as revealed by science you know
as well as well as we can get our little
minds around it at this point in our in
our species history you know connecting
those two things I think it's one of the
things that might both my parents or my
father was my mom is so gifted at and I
think that when we when we think that
some we lose something in clarity and
specificity when we think of it as as
less magical less beautiful when we
understand something deeply I think that
we rob ourselves of even greater
understanding an even deeper sense of
connectedness and you know ah but it's
it's really difficult to to present
sometimes you know I often say facts get
maligned as cold and hard you know we
have this idea that you know when you
just look at I mean the cold hard facts
right we have this idea that information
is unromantic that it's not beautiful
that it's not stirring and I think that
that's really short changes us and you
know mysteries are wonderful but we like
mysteries as you know when we get to
find out the ending when we get to find
out what happens you know and I think
that that curiosity I think you know
there's so much that we've come to
understand even over the last few
centuries that is so much more
astonishing in my opinion than we could
have ever imagined but when we take a
step back from it and actually look at
it it's very different than those things
that we sort of become accustomed to
understanding I mean you know I've read
about this like the idea that food grows
out of the ground because of water and
sunshine and you put it in your mouth
and you absorb the nutrients and you
live on I mean even something as simple
as that I think because we learn it when
we were very small children and we
learned that you know often people who
are sort of blase we jump we lose that
sort of astonishment about it but if you
are coming you know I don't know from
another planet or something and
everything was completely new every
little element of human life
reproduction genetics and not to mention
you know astronomy and evolution are so
beautiful and stirring and poetic if we
just talk about it in that way and sort
of emphasize the parts that are so
magnificent mm-hmm yeah you know you you
really hit on a bunch of themes there I
went on pack one of them is related to a
guest that we had on just this week in
honor of his book mario livio he wrote a
book of galileo in the science deniers
that's out now but his previous book was
called why what makes us curious and in
that book he and I spoke about this you
know if you sit down with your with your
daughter and you stand she asks you
about gravity and you start you know at
the inverse-square law and the geometric
metrics and you know she's going to lose
interest pretty quickly but in his mind
he says no teach teach the teach about
the dinosaurs you know I have what kid
is not interested in dinosaurs and you
mentioned they go through this in the
book going to the natural hist museum
with your dad as he as a child but what
so so say to them well say to her or any
in your life you know well this dinosaur
is not here because the thing called
gravity and something called an asteroid
and the asteroid was attracted to the
earth by gravitational forces and then
you tied into what they're naturally
thirsty for there's a quote in the
Talmud that you should teach a child
according to their ways you know not
what what aspect of a child is not more
kind of delicious and wonderful than
their curiosity totally agree with ya
and you bring this up in your book so
that so you know so delightfully you
talk about the theme of the book that
runs through again I'm not going to give
it away I want everyone to buy six
copies now now that's inflation now but
I want I want people to but but the book
goes through the seasons and you talk
about you know the reason for the season
is because of the the axial tilt of the
earth and how fascinating that is that
we have Passover you know if you're
religious or an Easter in the spring
because of this 23 and a half degree
tilt that the earth has and relative
tilt with respect to its orbital plane
and then you know I was thinking well
that'd be an amazing thing to start
teaching you know teaching little kids
they understand why the seasons are you
know they understand that serious
seasons are except here in La Jolla San
Diego pretty easy you know seasons here
it goes from you know 68 to 72 and then
we call a hot day but but yeah the
notion of you know of teaching came
across in the book as a form of ritual
and I wonder you know I was told that by
a Russian colleague that the word
scientist in the Russian language means
one who was taught and I think about
teaching as a ritual and as I said later
today I'm gonna engage in a ritual one
of my graduate students who's now a
professor Darcy Baron in New Mexico
she made this plaque that details our
academic family tree and it goes back it
goes back 19 generations now and
actually she has her own graduate
student at the University I've got 20
generations goes back to the 1500s and
and yet I feel like you know in the way
that we have and I have and one of my I
think my 14 students going to defend his
PhD and about it and about 90 minutes so
I want to talk about academic rituals
and and and the teacher learner
a mentor process and what it means to
you you were lucky to have wonderful you
know parents and teachers living in the
house with you and last night I set this
shocking video I don't know if you've
seen this but it's it's weird because
it's meant to be like comforting it's
this robot called moxie have you seen it
no that called moxie and I hope they
won't stop advertising with the into the
impossible podcaster it's a robot and
it's like you're supposed to put in the
room with your kid leave and the robot
is basically you could pass the Turing
test that a you know a four-year-old can
can muster and then it holds your kid's
hand and acid problems you know who's
who's bothering them at school and I
said it to my wife she's like that's so
creepy it's awful like why would you
want to do that and I was but there must
be a need like teaching is so difficult
this is teacher appreciation week here
in America at least so talk us through
the the ritual of Education of being a
parent being a child being a student
being a teacher well I think that the
the it's so funny because something like
is you're sending your thesis or
graduation it's also clearly into the
very traditional structure of a ritual
right you were apart from something
this is defined in this book called
rates of passage which sort of was the
early exploration of these things where
you start apart and it's the pre liminal
days and then liminal meaning threshold
is the ritual and then you go through
the threshold and you're together you
know and so like for example a wedding
is very traditional in this format your
part you have the original ceremony and
then they're together as a married
couple but with graduation right you're
you're apart from your degree from your
maybe new title from your you know
future career and you go through the
ritual and you say the magic words
whether you're given the magical paper
and you were deemed you know to have
passed through this threshold and now
you are someone else you are something
else you are part of something else and
so I think that there's there's so much
and you see it I mean just
anytime that there are like gowns and
hats involved you know and things that
we otherwise don't do you can think of
it as a ritual but in terms of the
everyday elements of it and I think you
can see this from really early in
childhood you know children are so
naturally curious and you're right it's
one of the most fabulous qualities about
a little person and it's I think so
often adults feel as some element of
insecurity if they don't have all the
answers and I was really lucky because I
had two amazingly brilliant parents but
also because they were so willing to say
when they didn't know the answer and
that was actually something that was
really celebrated like when I was small
and I could ask a question to which they
didn't know the answer it was like I had
done something really wonderful because
I was curious enough to get beyond the
knowledge of two very you know very
smart adults and it was like my brain
was working and so you know in those
days we would go over to the
encyclopedia and pull off the the right
volume and try to search for the answer
and this kind of homeless little
intellectual adventure was this family
activity and we would try to find a clue
towards what we were getting towards and
now because we all have the encyclopedia
and so much more in our pockets it's so
much easier and you know if you're like
in the car and your kid has a question
you know it used to be well when we get
home we can look it up and not you know
call over seriously but you know now
it's like if all these answers are with
you and of course we have to discern
sources and we have to take into account
where we're getting our information and
all sorts of ulterior motives and things
like that but the idea that we have
access to this you know and sometimes
it's very basic question you know what
year did something happen or who was
this person I've heard their name and I
don't know what they did or why I know
who they are you know I'd like to go
down those rabbit hole as if whoa what
about this and well when was that
together as a family is so special and
really is a ritual because you start
separated from the information you're
looking for you get there you read it
you research it you find what you're
looking for and then you're united in
this deeper understanding and when you
do as a family it's so special and you
know I think just getting comfortable in
general especially with small children
was the idea of saying I don't know the
answer to that it's a really good
question
is so oh it's such a I think it's it's
such a gift because then they don't feel
like they have to pretend that they know
everything and and they understand that
it's okay to not have all the
information but that it's more important
to follow the curiosity towards real
information rather than forcing an
answer and because we have such
discomfort with ambiguity was not
knowing and I also just think you end up
learning so much more and like my
daughter as such you know as I said
she's not through yet she's again
talking about like our relationship with
nature like and I mean when she sees the
moon she like freaks out like every time
like it's brand-new and amazing and like
what's through her eyes it is amazing
and and again I'm talking about gravity
and like there it is and it controls the
tides and it changes over the course of
the month and because of her fascination
with it now my husband and I are like
really well versed in the phases the
moon and like waning and waxing gibbous
and all this stuff but like you know she
nothing can on site recognize and it's
like it's like you're saying this was
something that she was curious about
nobody just a family of lunatics
listeners gave me a question to ask you
and there really connects to this
curiosity and to the moon and to being a
woman and his you know question is what
do you sort of make of the fact that in
his mind
the first astronomers might have been
women I mean actually knowing about the
connection between the monthly cycles
that they
enjoy or not but I haven't experienced
that myself but but the the point is you
know that he claims that people women
would have been the most keen observers
of the moon and the most influenced by
it and noted obviously with their vastly
superior intelligence that there's a
connection and there is this at monthly
ritual and you talk about it in the book
a little bit but I wonder if you could
walk us through that because it does
connect to exactly what you said your
curiosity
link to your biology link to the
astronomical right and so it's
fascinating because I always thought
that there was a you know scientific
evidence that supported why the
menstrual cycle was on the same ish
depending on the person scheduled as the
cycles of the Moon and when I went to
research for the book I was astonished
that there's no like hard evidence of a
connection which isn't to say that there
isn't a connection we just haven't
proven it yet so we have to sort of sit
in the ambiguity about it but the thing
that is so astonishing to me and
connects to this is how many disparate
cultures made their moon deities
goddesses female and that connection and
that sense of you know this
personification of these inanimate
objects which is you know and you know
in some cases in nature animates - but
this personification this idea that
there's a story to tell that connects to
us and also is a reflection it's so
often a mirror of our needs and wants
and fears and experiences and you see
that in so many different cultures
around the world and is so interesting
but I think you know I think in any
society pre you know certainly pre
electricity but pre domestication of
fire the moon has got to be a central
figure for anybody who has to like get
up in the night to pee or like do
anything when you know do you think
about how much more of an influence the
difference between a full moon and a new
moon was when there was no other light
at night
that's really haunting and and it makes
it so clear how important but this rock
you know that orchids us was to to our
our point of view for until very
recently yeah one other thing that I was
talking about with my wife this is sort
of my speculation but take it for what
it's worth that I believe that that
children you ever noticed that you know
grandchildren that said have a special
connection with with their grandparents
and it's because they have a common
enemy even even the maternal grandmother
is sort of privileged in a sense this
will make my mom she's the mother of
four boys but but actually the maternal
grandmother is even more connected
because in a sense your daughter he burn
aims higher are her middle name okay
yeah from the Greek so that she was when
she was born I believe that women are
born with all the eggs that they're
gonna have speaking so that means that
at one point all the eggs that are
inside of of Helena were instead of your
mother right yeah yeah are connected
indelibly well but they weren't in
therefore it was I think it's when your
what you have to develop unless you know
as a fetus before you're going to where
all the eggs are but the genetic
information right well the day you were
born
allegedly right you would have the egg
that became her right so that means that
egg was inside of you which is inside of
her so just like that that connection of
birth and and also I you know like you
know as Mother's Day is coming up and
you just think about the unbroken chain
back to the earliest humans and beyond
of this relationship and you know it's
not always the person who raises you
it's not always the person who you feel
that connection to but some somewhere
you grew inside of someone and that that
chain going back is I find really moving
and and and again at one of those things
that you
when you're very small you know the
babies come from inside somebody's womb
and it's very I thought when I was
reading it and talked when you talked
about when she was born and I said I
think it's true and I this might be one
of my you know many done Slee things to
say but I believe the belly button
is the only thing on the human body that
doesn't change size as you get because
it's not determined by you it's
determined by the umbilical cord that
went to your mother's post all right
yeah so I always joke you know your mom
have made you to my kids but you know I
made your belly button yes I'm one who
I'm really fascinated with too is all
the things that we don't really call
rituals or see as rituals that are a
part of these big experiences and a part
of daily life that are really poetic in
a way when you when you look at them but
we sort of just like that's right yeah
they're that they're the ones that are
just pacing back and forth most of the
time trying not to faint I think you
know modern man my contemporaries and I
are you know we're trying to step it up
a little bit more especially now we're
doing our best we're standing on the
shoulders of giants
namely our our wives and mothers so I
want to start wrapping up as I know
you've got so many demands on your time
and I want to ask a little bit about
about you know again about your mom this
maybe will make this the Mother's Day
edition of the International podcast but
but the kinds of wisdom you know I
always say that that science means
knowledge in Latin it doesn't mean
wisdom and I feel like you know you you
certainly got this this curiosity some
of it was genetic some of it was you
know was genetic or learned by you and
develop but what kinds of lessons that
they communicate with you I mean do you
have these recordings I
I say things like this you know all the
time and you know like and it's just
parroting back with my mother or father
late father used to say to me and I
wonder you know are there kind of
ethical or wisdom lessons that have come
through from these from you from your
parents that come through to you and and
you know if that enabled you are guided
you to take on it's a huge production I
always say people say you know having a
writing a book is as close to having a
baby as a man can have and I'm like an
idiot like I'm sorry like you know I was
drinking like lattes most of the time
when I was writing my book but but you
know in in the case of you coming from
this did you feel pressure did you feel
an obligation there's so many people
that you meet and you talk about in the
book and people meet you you're Carl
Sagan's daughter you know and for you
the painful aspects and ask you how he
is or or they ask you you know something
about like well you must be over that by
now what kind of pressure did you feel
if any to you know keep up the Sagan
name obviously and to keep these
traditions of your mother and your
father going and the artistic and
artistic science adjacent and with
curiosity but also just this idea of you
know trying to as you're researching
just trying to get it right if you make
a mistake admit it do what you can to
change it I'm sure there are mistakes in
the book the only thing is you talk
about Yom Kippur the things that you're
that you're supposed to do and you're
not supposed to do and you say in
Leviticus it says you're not supposed to
drink but it actually doesn't say that
it just says oh it says you shall
afflict yourself actually this is
interesting let me ask ya the actual
quote is you shall afflict yourself and
then the pharisees the rabbinical you
know leaders of the the early you know
part of the Talmudic epoch they decided
affliction means that you don't eat or
drink but it totally made up by that
anywhere in the Torah in the Old
Testament Oh
that's fascinating thank you for telling
me and yet we all do it right we all do
all fast or we try to write yeah we
don't but but anyway so it's carried on
through this ultra Orthodox sect you
know and without that we wouldn't do
this ritual that even the most reform
you know liberated or whatever however
you want to say it Jews practice and I
wonder why that is what I mean that we
take these traditions from from
religious sects that there's so much
more you know conservative in a small C
yeah then we are deep do you have
anything that's so you're saying that
even the fasting yeah is not because
like myself people don't look into what
you know the original languages and I
think because we fasting I mean that
chapter talking and fasting is so such a
clear way of saying I am giving
something up and over ritual if you can
you are experiencing this physically
it's not just going through the motions
you know you're really having this
physical experience that I think people
crave something like that you know one
day or you know depending on different
religions and different cultures it's
you know from sunrise sundown for a
month or whatever it is I think that
there is this element of wanting that
almost physical connection to the ritual
but or it's just they're like
grandmother told me to do so I'm gonna
do it I got so much right I mean charity
as you say fasting is good for people
nowadays meditation prayer there are
there's so many good things that are
concomitant with with the you know and I
think if people got away from this
feeling as you seem to have gotten the
way for you know that you you are in a
sense you are choosing the things that
appeal to you and choosing not to do the
things that don't appeal to you
obviously that's not a standard you know
Orthodox Jew but and it's kind of
tailored to you but you seem to accept
it it may not continue with you know
Helena or whoever else but that's okay
because you have determined a kind of
you know Gestalt for your own life and
how you want and the values that you're
communicating are the essence the code
that you want to transmit into the
future I think that's obviously yeah you
know I guess pressure anything that that
I haven't really experienced this
feeling I mean I think anyone wants so
like positively reflect on their parents
I would imagine and I definitely feel
that way but I never felt a pressure
that I had to like live up to something
so much as like the book I I felt like
it was more than like the pressure of
like having something inside me that I
wanted to write about and vote like
actually getting it down on paper almost
felt like a relief rather than a source
of stress if that makes sense
and I think that you know when you like
you know write something it's because
you like need to and then that's the
only reason it's alright and it's also
to somebody else that's wonderful but
it's like it's almost really selfish
because it's like you have to get this
out there and like I just I don't know I
was really lucky to have the parents and
have my mom that I have and you know I
think that the emphasis on questioning
and the willingness to hear questions
and the willingness to tolerate
ambiguity you know is something that's
so hard to do as a parent or just as a
human being and it's something that they
really gave me as a gift at you know to
be able to say I don't know should be
able to say some things are you know
really mysterious still we don't have
all the answers and we may get some
someday and other things we won't but
that life on on this little planet is so
profoundly beautiful even if this is all
there is
yeah precious and fleeting right yeah I
didn't as I read it you know I was
thinking when I wrote my book you know
how had my father react to it and you
know he was he was a militant atheist my
late father and he used to say things
like I don't believe in God but I do
believe in the devil because he made you
believe in God you know I mean he was
very seriously a militant against it
it's a refreshing and quite lovely to
see you know your father who is known
for you know the books of kind of and
you must know this that there's scornful
kind of reviews of the detrimental
effect that Carl Sagan's Cosmos had and
Andrian had on unbelievers because it
was seen by a billion people around the
world and I'm like if your faith is so
paper-thin that you you can't use it not
only to not damage your faith but to
increase your faith if you believe you
should know the most about science
because it will provide you the clearest
window maybe not the only one but the
clearest window into this magical you
know almost mysterious processes by
which God if you believe if you don't
that's fine I don't really care
but you know created the world or what
purpose the world might have I don't
know I'm looking for it and I think
every day is a mysterious delicious
puzzle I want to just take the
opportunity because some of the
listeners have asked questions on
Twitter and elsewhere one thing is and I
don't know if you can even answer this
but but in contact though one list is
asking the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence is coming from looking
originally comes from Jodie Foster /
Jill tarter hearing this radio impulses
on a row large radio telescope the Very
Large Array which I am privileged to go
and review every so often as part of my
service to the to the astronomical
community it's a wonderful facility but
she hears it using radio signals after
you know we're now celebrating basically
the sixtieth year of the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence with which
your debt was deeply involved and I
wonder what would he say about the state
you know we haven't found anything and
you know you're a big believer in
evidence and belief but you know we have
no
that they exist positive evidence at
what point you know would he give up do
you think or would you let's just say
personally at what point do you turn the
telescope's off because we don't have
infinite resources on this perilous
planet you know when do you give up a
search and and just reside with the
feeling that you may never know well we
may never know whether we search or or
we don't but I think that it's very it's
an answer to a deep and profound
question to know if this is if it's just
us or not and you know I think my dad's
curiosity about that was very profound
and - - and again you know this is one
of those things where people would say
what kind of gem and say well what do
you think and he would say I don't know
um and they would say yeah but like what
is your gut telling you and I try not to
use my gut for this sort of thing I try
to use my mind and I think you know it
is an important question and is a
profound question and and as long as we
can try to gain a little more evidence
I think whatever the answer is we it's
nothing we could possibly guess and so
it is worth trying to find out I'm gonna
tell us this either way the answer tells
us so much about ourselves
hmm very nice and I guess the last kind
of comment or question that people are
interested in hearing from you if you
can kind of profess that you know for on
behalf of your father but I actually
don't care I'll change it to you just to
you but at some level there is a there
is an element of belief even to
scientist I see it in my field I did a
video online about the multi-verse
versus faith in God and which which sort
of you know what differences and
similarities do they have and and all
the comments are that are negative or
all about you know God is this is this
is terrible and no scientist believes in
things they always have evidence and I
think for something like the multiverse
which may you know according to the
brightest minds and science don't just
listen to me maybe unprovable because it
posits the existence of a perhaps
infinite number of other universes
similar to the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence there may
be life that existed a billion years ago
on a gal
see that's you know you know 30 30
million light years away we'll never get
in contact will never receive evidence
for it so when you wrestle with that how
how did did your father or do you
reconcile that that notion of just of
anything that you have lack of evidence
for it doesn't mean evidence of lack but
it does mean it does as a human instill
you know some something nagging I think
and and God could be one of those things
for someone who is who is a believer or
maybe struggling with belief I mean you
know scientists are human beings you
know of course we all have experiences
fervor invested in something we want
something to be true or we want
something to not be true and that colors
are our approach in our view and our
language around it but I think that you
know there's a difference between
positing a possibility saying that this
is how this could work or here's some
evidence that suggests it and being open
to scrutiny and being open to following
the evidence wherever it leads I think
that there's a difference between that
and making to paraphrase my dad making
an extraordinary claim without having
extraordinary evidence to support it so
you know of course you know imagination
is central to any kind of exploration or
understanding we have to have some wild
ideas to get to you know I don't know go
to the moon do anything that we've ever
done you know create an airplane sail
across an ocean you know these require a
very adventuresome imagination right
right otherwise it can't be done but I
think those those endeavors only work
when we follow the evidence and see
where it leads and and see what can
stand up to scrutiny at what will
actually float and what wall great ok I
want to finish up since you mentioned
imagination we are the arthur c-- clark
center for human imagination and this is
the into the impossible podcast the
words into the impossible derive
from sir arthur c clarke second law
which is that the only way to to find
out what is possible is to venture a
little bit beyond into the impossible
and i want you to take out a telescope
in your mind and look back at a 20 year
old sasha and and give her some advice
what things did you once feel were
perhaps impossible that you managed to
do and and advise her but that by
venturing into the impossible you were
able to accomplish oh it's such a good
question i think you know the thing that
I think surprises me most about that
everybody would be most surprised by it
twenty about myself at 37 is actually
touching on what you were saying earlier
about the writing a book being like
having a baby I was a terrible
procrastinator most of my life certainly
when I was 20 years old in college
waiting until the night before to start
writing papers and I started writing
like really writing my book right after
my daughter was born and I would have
imagined that that would not have been
possible but there was something about
the urgency of knowing like I had to go
relieve the babysitter in three hours
I better not sit and look at Instagram
which of course 20 year old me would
have been like what's that oh you know I
gotta actually put some paper some words
on this piece of paper I think that that
that bad idea that sometimes the most
difficult work you have to do can be
done more easily under a higher pressure
situation than it can be when you have
all the time in the world I think that's
what would surprise me well I want to
continue on that theme of books the two
questions I have are related to books
and actually a quote very famous quote
from the 11th episode of the 1980 series
cosmos called the persistence of memory
your father Carl Sagan said what an
astonishing thing a book is what amis
punishing thing
a book is it's a flat object made from a
tree with flexible parts on which are
imprinted lots of funny dark squiggles
but one glance at it and you're inside
the mind of another person maybe
somebody did for thousands of years
across the millennia an author is
speaking clearly and silently inside
your head directly to you writing is
perhaps the greatest of human inventions
binding together people who never knew
each other citizens of distant epochs
books break the shackles of time a book
is proof that humans are capable of
working magic magic first of all want to
thank you for alerting me to the fact
which I didn't know that magic comes
from the word Magi which I never knew
which you've discovered and talked about
for me so thank you for that but let's
talk about books for a second you you
wrote this book and I do feel like books
are sort of human created DNA in that it
really impels us to communicate not just
our knowledge because I think you know
Wikipedia like you were saying before
it's encyclopedia Britannica's a lot
more facts and knowledge and all our
have but it doesn't have any wisdom and
I wonder you know what books mean to you
or they have the same kind of resonance
as with your father in that in that it
really does communicate from his mind to
our minds and and do you wish that he
had written is his own autobiography
there is a biography of him but not a
lot of those are all really good
questions yeah I mean when I think about
a book I think about time travel I
really do yeah I think about the idea
that you can as as you said be inside
the mind of someone and you know
whatever is written today that that can
that can survive on longer than the
lifespan of the writer is really
profound and moving I
that there's something about that that's
that's really stirring and something
that probably would have seemed
impossible to people who lived in a time
before the written word sorry I mean in
terms of him writing an autobiography I
mean my mom and I have talked about this
and there are a few biographies about of
him you know it's so hard it's so hard
to write your own life it's so hard to
have someone else write your life you
know that is a form of time travel that
we have not yet mastered whether it's
your your own words or someone else's
you know to really understand fully what
the life of someone else was at a time
when you were not present in a full
picture is really hard all we can really
do is get little glimmers through
individual stories and experiences and
anecdotes and I cherish the ones I have
you know the ones that he shared
publicly and the ones that I just got to
hear at the dining room table of him
especially as a little boy in
Bensonhurst and Brooklyn playing
handball and just you know being like a
kid one of my most joyful things is
imagining him as a little was a little
boy in the 1930s and 40s in New York
definitely definitely a time I'd like to
travel today okay last question just
about books is who would you choose if
you could only give this to one one
person or you know a group of people
would it be to Orthodox Jews devout
Muslims Christians born-again Christians
or would it be to militant atheist
skeptics you know as so-called secular
humanists if you could only have one
group read this book who would it be for
I would like if I had one crew a third
option it would be people who sort of
identify as spiritual but not religious
you know I think that there is you know
people are very developed or you know in
either direction if they're very devout
religious
we're very devout atheist you know
that's they're all set the people who I
really would be so delighted to have
read my book are people who want that
connection to nature to the earth to the
Stars and don't feel it from religion
but and are sort of vulnerable to be
getting swept up in things like
astrology or crystals or things like
that that are not supported by evidence
and maybe feel a little bit unsatisfied
by that but it feels like some of that
that's thrilling for lack of a better
word magic spiritual sense of being part
of the cosmos and part of the planet I
think I think that there's a there's a
way forward that is evidence-based and
still gives you that that joy that we
all crave in different ways great well
this book as it's been described is a
memoir it's a guidebook for the
perplexed and where they fit in and in
this great vast beautiful cosmos that
she and her family are the first family
of this cosmos so sashawna thank you so
much can you just tell people really
quickly where to find you where to find
your book what other projects you might
want them to be interested in in the
future
I'm sure thank you so much Brian you can
find my book anywhere that you get books
support support your local bookstore if
you can and you can find me on Instagram
and Twitter at Sascha Segan and my
website is lush thinking back home and I
look forward to to hearing any questions
and corrections that's a sign of an
intellectually honest author with that I
lose that I used to pay my my kids to
find typos in the book but though oh
that's good yeah one of them one of them
found a typo in Anna Percy Jackson book
but we're having trouble tracking down
the dollar from the author of the Percy
Jackson
well anyway as I said I have a ritual to
get off to a part of a thousand-year-old
Academical tradition I want to thank you
for instilling meaning in and
participating in this and I don't know
su especially a happy mother's day Sasha
I really hope you have a wonderful
meaningful day this this week you
deserve it and I look forward to all
your future projects thank you so much
for coming on the podcast
my pleasure Brian thank you so much
[Music]